it's Saturday night which means it's
time to take it cheap
[Music]
if you paid attention to the media you
were convinced it was once again the end
of the frickin world kind of like this
be here murdering the children of
Americans say you know what's hard when
the present United sanctuary to you to
beat the hell out of him now you know
I'd say that's worse than the view but
it is the view let me break it to you
America stuff is good jobs economy if
Trump is in anyone's pockets it's yours
and he's dumping wads of cash in it
we're powerful we're prosperous were
peaceful we're happy at least happier
than we were under Obama that's from a
poll I believe polls according to that
same poll this is great this is great
most people know that the media's nuts
fewer than 1% think Russia is a big deal
the meat is completely preoccupied by
something less than 1% care about how
disconnected can you be in terms of
significance to most Americans
Russia's tied with my third nipple it's
an adorable one but I get it it's hard
to tell what matters with our media
every day their hair is on fire and I
include this chap who has none
so many cartoon Cronkite's what we all
saw and heard in Helsinki today is
really frightening an absolutely
shameful display by an American
president with the whole world watching
as you see behind me there's a little
bit of a gloom now it's set in right
after the world witnessed a betrayal the
likes of which we've never seen
America's president sided with its enemy
today shock has turned to a national
shunning as America finds unity and
president Trump's perfidy perfidy
somebody found out the Souris are they
they make Chicken Little a comatose now
Trump is invited get this has tried
bided Putin to America the media screams
but I love it you know the media says
please please please don't do X and
Trump says here's x-squared
he knows you can't win with the media
who can't see what's obvious to the rest
of us we know the real world looks
nothing like what they see
here's MSNBC's coverage of Trump's last
press conference
[Applause]
[Music]
the reality your life's actually getting
better yet the media's mentality keeps
getting worse why is that it's because
in their heads they're watching
something totally different the media
sees the news as a scripted event and
they're furious Trump won't read from
their script he reads from his own so
while the media panics over Trump's
refusal to play the lead in their movie
he stars in his own building up the
military demanding NATO pay for their
defense toying with Putin's pipeline
army Ukraine
it's like sergeant Rock versus the Three
Stooges but if Trump is Putin's stooge
he's doing a total Curly to their mo do
they really think deal-making is how you
destroy America Minds me of a movie in
1962 the world met the Manchurian
Candidate he was an American prisoner of
war brainwashed by communists into being
an unwitting assassin against his own
country now comes the long-awaited
sequel they haven't ever had to reckon
with the possibility that somebody has
ascended to the presidency of the United
States to serve the interests of another
country rather than our own he was a
real estate mogul turned reality show
host but then a foreign power
in their sleeper agent it was a shocking
display of surrender unlike anything
we've seen from an American president
but what the enemy didn't know was that
when he finally rose to the top he do
unspeakable things like cutting taxes
lowering the unemployment rate demanding
NATO allies pay their fair share
growing the economy and neutralizing
nuclear threats nude man on a unicorn
surfing on a breadstick teaching another
unicorn how to surf on a breadstick
films presents Vladimir Putin Chris
Matthews and Donald Trump as the worst
Manchurian Candidate ever Manchurian
Candidate - the worst Manchurian
Candidate ever
so obvious it's so obvious for Trump a
Russia deal is just a deal like buying
the car except it's peace and prosperity
watch any good salesmen and you'll see
somebody ignoring all the negatives and
zeroing in on the close the past is the
past
until after the handshake which is why
Trump doesn't get all the outrage over
this he's like every husband who says
the wrong thing and doesn't know why
he's suddenly ducking a potted plant
it's true after all dialogue is a very
important thing and it's a very good
thing
dialogue is a very important thing and
it's a very good thing
how easy is that to follow
he knows being polite to a thug it's a
small price to pay to neutralize a few
nuclear threats I'll give you a pat on
the back in public Vlad if you give a
Syria Iran North Korea and fix your damn
alphabets I mean what the hell is this I
don't know
in reality Putin is just another mob
boss you got a Greece to get that new
casino off the ground so in the press
fantasy anytime Trump is polite to
anyone that's proof of conspiracy in
reality though is having conversations
with Putin or Kim the same as colluding
no wonder collusions in the air it's
made out of nothing no you avoid
conflict through conversation sorry you
can't just ignore Russia like it's Jim
Acosta at a press conference
yet so many progressives eight progress
ironically Trump may do more for the
cause of peace than any left limping
president ever could because he's
dealing from a position of strength what
a surprise
a 73 year old billionaire who dealt with
thugs his whole life is succeeding where
a grad student who writes bad poetry
couldn't how is that he got the stick
and the carrot in the right order you
build up the military that's the stick
then comes the carrot liberals do the
opposite they declare sticks a threat to
the environment then they bury our
enemies in carrots but Trump dealing
with Putin in Trump's pocket is a big
stick and he's not just happy to see him
let's welcome tonight's guests if he
ever becomes a porn star he won't have
to change his name former CIA officer
and radio TV host
buck Sexton practicing her name I'm
practicing her name she's our business
reporter from north of the border the
best Canadian import since Molson beer
Fox Business Network reporter Christina
parts anabella's yeah what's it about
she's so bright the Sun seeks shade from
her natural review reporter cat Tim I
could say her name just like the Vatican
he's famous for his mass that's a great
one WWE Superstar massive side kisses
kick pirates
Freudian slip
I'm Brett but I love this week I love
this week it was hilarious everyday I
was laughing it was the Super Bowl of
snowflake ISM it was like nothing I've
ever seen in my life you've never seen
so much pearl clutching in fact wherever
you set the boundaries of what's too
crazy for mainstream media publications
to say okay look press conference wasn't
amazing you know this isn't the Second
Coming of matter Nick like I can
understand why some people might have
some issues here right but it's not as
bad as Pearl Harbor somebody even
compared it to Kristallnacht like is
this just because you don't want to do
the usual Hitlerian things you decided
to get specific these people completely
lost their minds and now we're at the
end of the week and then we know people
don't care about it because we got
avenatti back on TV yeah so this is the
loop this is the screw it's true now
it's back to porn stars and sex the way
I like it
ladies and gentlemen all right Christina
you cover money in business and you do
it well at Fox Business the economy
seems immune to any of this stuff and
Americans seem immune it's true it's
true we just hit the lowest unemployment
rate that we've seen since 1969 I needed
to appreciate that date and then we're
also both since you've talked about your
third nipple already
[Applause]
but more importantly yes is doing well
we had a bunch of earnings that came out
this week very very strong however
because I cover business news my only
caller is green we have to be concerned
about the trade tariffs I agree and
inflation comes to and lack of wage
growth so I'm worried factors that can
weigh heavily on the economy I'm worried
and if that stuff happens and goes south
he's going to be in a bit of a trouble
because he's taking credit for this big
boom right now and if it goes south he's
gonna get hit mm-hmm by the media cat
what do you say about the second summit
aren't you excited Putin's gonna come
here maybe I'll go to Mira Lago maybe we
could throw him a military parade I know
that there's going to be a lot of
outrage even if it goes well it doesn't
really matter because we saw with this
press conference this this week we saw
Trump saying the exact same things as
he's been saying since he was a
candidate saying he wanted to get along
with Putin you may like it you may not
like it but it's not new and yet
everybody reacted as if it was some sort
of crazy new thing it wasn't some crazy
new thing it was exactly what he's been
saying it's almost as if people aren't
actually paying attention to the news
and just when they see other people get
mad they get mad too because they want
to all be in a nice little mad Club
where they all just breathe on each
other really heavily I agree it's all
about being mad tires anything bothering
you about this yeah I'm pissed I'll tell
you why it never should have happened
yeah and it has nothing to do with
anything you think he made him wait an
hour Putin made him wait I would have
left my girl in the house and she made
me wait 15 minutes this is the United
States of America Jack we wait for no
one when he got there should be a little
intern name where I going I'm sorry you
missed the president miss Putin maybe
next time like yeah that's the only I
was mad about we don't wait we don't
wait you out your mind but whatever okay
I'll let that pass the press conference
to me I always look at things through my
life yeah half and I bit out at a
restaurant with lots of friends mm-hmm
and maybe you're having some issues at
home yeah and the press is the angry
girlfriend yes who decides to bring up
something
personal why are you trying to entertain
friends and you have that awkward why
would you bring that up here I'm with my
friends what the hell and that's
basically what happened with Donald
Trump in the presence I ask the
questions you see another going so
you're gonna bring up my bastard child
right now mr. comedian like this is the
place we need to bring this up like I'm
sorry Reverend just give me a saying why
you do this wherever we go out this is
why I'll take you nowhere it's love
child yeah no but it's true it's like he
is saying I'm trying to deal with this
guy we can talk about that stuff later
voice it's pretty good what I'm sorry
no that wasn't imitating you Christina
because there was no air from the
Canadians I don't drink Molson what do
you drink garbage what it is garbage
they're our sponsors I don't know I'm
excited I'm excited I'm excited for the
next summit I can't wait I hope I get to
go